[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt
heute gibt's ne wickeltorte als Eistorte
denn ich finde es wird mal wieder Zeit
für Eistorte und die Torte ist wirklich
schnell gemacht sie sieht kompliziert
und aufwendig aus ich liebe so Torten
die so aussehen weil man damit einfach
mega prahlen kann und sagen ja schau was
ich für dich gebacken habe und es ist
einfach so wir backen eine Biskuitplatte
wie bei so einer Biskuitrolle und das
ganze dauert halt als mein wähnen
Küchenmaschine habt könnt ihr in der
Zeit sowieso etwas anderes machen und im
Prinzip habt ihr eine Arbeitszeit von
ungefähr
neun Minuten Kühlzeit im Gefrierfach 2
Stunden
30 Minuten und
es ist erst mal den Ofen
200 Grad ober Unterhitze
100 Gramm Zucker und Mehl dafür gebe ich
jetzt einfach die zimmerwarme Meyer in
die Rührschüssel gemeinsam mit Salz
Vanilleextrakt und Zucker und die Masse
wird dann für etwa zehn bis 15 Minuten
schön cremig gerührt ich nutz die
Zwischenzeit und werd schon mal die
Zutaten ausrichten für den nächsten Step
falls ihr mit dem Handrührgerät arbeitet
hört euch ein Podcast von uns an oder
macht Musik an und chillt einfach 15
Minuten im Handrührgerät
wo kann man die Zeit überbrücken
[Musik]
jetzt ist die Masse richtig schön cremig
aufgeschlagen
sagen es ist einfach immer wieder
faszinierend lieb ist wird auch gut und
dann ist sie einfach Mehl dazugeben
immer aus wie so ein Wasserfall und
ganz vorsichtig und behutsam das Mehl
ist unterheben
ich mag das ganze auf meinem oder in
meinem Backrahmen auf dem Lochblech geht
am schnellsten und ich habe wirklich nur
eine Backzeit von 9 Minuten immer ganz
exakt bei mir weil ich einfach weiß wie
der Ofen funktioniert und bei Biskuit
Platten einfach immer drauf achten kurz
und heiß backen und dann brechen sie
auch nicht beim Aufrollen daher auch die
hohe Temperatur von 210 Grad und
natürlich Ober-Unterhitze und nicht
Heißluft dann heißt es wird schon ein
bisschen bissel Austrocknen das nehme
ich dann nur bei anderen Gebäcken wie
Käsekuchen zum Beispiel vertrocknet
nichts aus
daher hier
schön glatt verstreichen und sofort
backen nicht stehen lassen und in den
neuen minuten Joschi schaffen dass wir
schaffen die neun Minuten den Oberboden
ok ich
habe die Zutaten schon gerichtet
[Musik]
jetzt schnell in den heißen Ofen und
dann zeige ich euch die Zutaten für den
Boden
[Musik]
trinkverbot nehme ich 120 Gramm Butter
50g Amaretti Kekse 100g Butter Kekse ich
habe jetzt hier die Vollkorn Variante
und jeweils 30g krispl das sind die mit
Karamellgeschmack und Haselnüsse und die
sind gehackt und geröstet okay jetzt
könnt ihr zuerst die Butter schmelzen
entweder in der Mikrowelle oder im Topf
der Walker wurde der ursprünglich dass
du erfunden Oma hat Fleisch beim
Anbraten so so krümelig anzutreffen dass
ich eben da da hackfleischkloß nicht so
als bloß zusammen bildet aber ich bin
der wacker der ist einfach für mich beim
Allzweckgerät für Porridge also wenn es
Bananen zerdrücken oder wenn ich
Kartoffelstampf mache oder Gemüse oder
irgendwie Kekse Wahrheit auch eine
größere Schüssel nehmen können aber ist
okay
und dafür ist es echt gut
dann kommt jetzt hier die Butter dass du
das immer so ein Glücksspiel mit der
Butter und den Butterkeksen denn je nach
Sorte braucht man mehr oder weniger
Butter weil eben jede kekstorte auch in
unterschiedlichen Fettgehalt hat und
jetzt normale Butterkekse nehmen brauche
ich auch weniger Butter wenn ich
Vollkorn nehme brauche ich bisschen mehr
welche Trockner sind Haferkekse brauchen
weniger da könnt ihr wirklich also
haltet euch ruhig an mein Rezept aber
wenn mal der Norbert Boden einfach zu
trocken ist gib dir einfach noch einen
Sprung Butter dazu und wenn er zu nass
ist einfach nur zehn Kekse das ist echt
so ja kommt halt auf den Keks drauf an
sind optimistisch und die Krispel
treiben die Küste sind echt mega die
habe ich ja in vier verschiedenen
Geschmacksrichtungen
gibt es drei Schokosorten Zartbitter
weiß und freue mich dann geht's Ruby und
dann gibt es noch die Karamell
und die sind schon toll weil man die
nicht nur für die Deko benutzen kann
sondern wirkt ja auch als Geschmack die
haben so ein Keks Kern in der Mitte und
der bringt einfach überall leckeren
Schwanz mit rein ich mag die auch mal
mit klar löst sich da die Schokolade und
schmilzt bisschen aber so vom Geschmack
her die machen echt Muffins und Kuchen
schon sehr sehr lecker
[Musik]
alles ist gut verrührt
stewmaker
ein
tortenretter Backfolie und einen
Tortenring der ist bereits auf 24cm
eingestellt und da kommt die Masse jetzt
rein wenn ich jetzt keine fruchtige
Torte machen würde dann würde ich jetzt
hier vielleicht sogar noch in den Boden
Frucht mit reinbringen das heißt
gefriergetrocknete Früchte Cranberry
schmeckt auch immer ganz gut aus könnt
ihr ruhig auch machen aber ich bringe
den fruchtigen Part oben in in die Torte
mit rein als könnte ich hier alles schön
glatt drücken und den obig wurden in den
Kühlschrank stellen ja
eine Minute dann ist der Biskuit fertig
das zeige ich euch direkt wie man ihn
zum schnellen Abkühlen bekommt
nein nicht das Gefrierfach nein
[Musik]
woher ab 10 Uhr
nimmt ihr euch einfach ein
schnell kühlt das Drehteam
und dann kann das nämlich so hoch setzen
damit es von unten nicht schwitzt
und eben durch dann auch einen anderen
Gegenstand
und so lasse ich es jetzt mal ganz kurz
etwa 2-3 Minuten abkühlen und sobald die
erste Hitze raus ist
ja das möcht ich mit rein und für die
Creme nehme ich 500 Gramm Quark 80 Gramm
Puderzucker 1 Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt
400 g Sahne und seiner Party steigt lang
also Marmelade mit Tank avanca
[Musik]
und dann kann er direkt weitergehen mit
der Creme dafür nehme ich Quark ihr
könnt auch Mascarpone nehmen
Magerquark habe ich jetzt ihr könnt aber
auch ein Sahnequark benutzen je mehr
Fettgehalt umso cremiger natürlich aber
kommt ja auch Sahne mit rein von daher
nicht so schon ganz passend
Quark habe ich immer gerne weil es so
eine leichte schöne Säure hat
Puderzucker
und Vanilleextrakt
kurz verrühren
dann die Sahne langsam dazu gießen und
[Musik]
dann ist ganze mit San apart steif
schlagen pro 100 Gramm Masse also pro
100 Gramm Sahne und Quark einfach einen
Teelöffel mich nehme da immer meine
Messlöffel damit ganz exakt gemessen
werden kann immer schön flach und
dazugeben
[Musik]
am Ende immer so nicht aus den Augen
verlieren sonst kann es echt schön
Versehen das Butterbrot wird den
kontrolliere ich sie mal lieber kurz
fertig
jetzt geht's schon ans füllen der Torte
einmal kurz vom Blech ziehen
und jetzt wird der Biskuit in Streifen
geschnitten ich muss jetzt erstmal aus
der müsste aber eigentlich wie immer so
ungefähr 36 haben
20-30 ich werde die Torte nicht allzu
hoch machen und schneide deswegen 5 cm
breite Streifen und die sollten jetzt
ganz genau sein also wirklich genau
damit die Torte später richtig richtig
schön wird
[Musik]
und dann einmal sauber durchschneiden
und jetzt bestreiche ich den erstmal mit
der Marmelade
[Musik]
und darüber verteile ich meine Creme
bald wieder eine saubere Palette oder
die andere kurz säubern und hier an den
Rand könnt ihr dann immer schöne
Teigkarte setzen
damit komme ich nicht über diesen Rand
hinaus und alles wird wunderschönen
glatt
[Musik]
erstmal abnehmen
und gerne auch schon die Backfolie
wenn ich jetzt die Menge gut kalkuliert
habe dann kommt hoffentlich genau hin
ich nehme es den obersten Part und da
außen da ist es ja auch nicht ganz glatt
das heißt da achte ich jetzt nur drauf
dass ich praktisch diese Außenkante dir
eben nicht geschnitten ist nach unten
bleibt damit ich oben und schönen
glatten Abschluss habt ihr werde ich
jetzt den ersten Part einfach mal
aufräumen so einer kleinen mini
Biskuitrolle
in die Mitte setzen
ich werde doch die beste Platte ganz
kurz kühlen und zwar damit die einzelnen
Streifen denn ich würde schon gerne
naked lassen damit die einzelnen
Streifen hier diese drei Schichten schön
haben kurz einmal entlang Streifen
streichen
und dann kann ich drumrum wechseln den
ersten muss ich gleich bisschen sauber
machen
dann wirds gut
[Musik]
ich denke jetzt warum jetzt geht's
besser
es klappt gut
es wird schön
Sallys schön macht Tipps für Torten
ja ist generell so wenn die Creme
einfach noch zu zu weich ist und ihr
wollt sowas machen lieber kurz kühl
stellen und ich hatte die Platte jetzt
für 10 Minuten im Gefrierfach ihr könnt
aber auch den Kühlschrank nehmen und
da einfach so lange bis die Creme so ein
bisschen im Bett ist
ich bin richtig glücklich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
is beautiful Bad mein Boden ist der groß
minimal aber das macht nichts ich
schneide ihn aus dem Weg
ich dachte vorher noch ich mach 22cm und
dann war ich so
nema 24 und das ist doch 22
Schleimer drumrum weg und habe ich noch
Apple crumble für oben drauf was ich
nämlich bisher tatsächlich noch nie
gemacht habe ist eine wickeltorte die
oben offen bleibt ich habe die immer
abgedeckt und ich finde aber eigentlich
diese Spirale richtig schön
und deswegen wollte ich dir einfach mal
offen lassen ich
lege jetzt hier ne tortenrandfolie
drumrum einfach nur damit der Biskuit
nicht an meinem Tortenring hängt denn
die Torte sollte jetzt schon noch ein
bisschen stabilisiert werden das eine
hat gereicht
ich benutze ja immer wieder deswegen
habe ich da immer so ein paar
abgeschnittenen Teile im Schrank und den
Ring einfach nur damit die Torte eine
schöne runde Form bekommt und so kann
man sie einfach nur so ein bisschen
zusammendrücken
ganz vorsichtig
wonderful und so kommt die ins
Gefrierfach und kann dann gleich nur
noch aus dekoriert werden und ihr könnt
es entweder eine komplett gefrorene
Torte machen oder eine angefroren
Trottel ich bin bei so Torten er fern
von angefroren also so ein bis zwei
Stunden aber können sie auch durch
frieren und auch nach Belieben beim
Auftauen so ein bisschen wieder antauen
lassen von daher wer die Torte jetzt
fertig ich kann die Küche säubern und
werden später aus dekorieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nimm richtig viele Johannisbeeren dieses
Jahr
das ist schön für mich vergessen
Früchte zu kaufen bzw ich habe mir
gedacht wenn ihm einfach ein paar aus
dem Garten so können wir die Torte schön
fertig dekorieren
und Blümchen okay jetzt die Torte fertig
dekoriert sagen dass es die Vorderseite
und ich habe mir gedacht wir machen nur
so einen kleinen Bogen ich habe auch
noch ein bisschen Creme übrig gelassen
und diese crumble die ich noch retten
konnte vor Sarah denn sara Lee
knobelboden jetzt versteh aufgegessen
und dann habe ich jetzt starb das
brauche ich noch gucken wir die Früchte
einfach so hinlegen
mir mithelfen
Himbeeren Heidelbeeren Johannisbeeren
[Musik]
ich gebe dir noch ein paar crumbles
drauf
und schön oder
kurz und fährt dann noch will kann noch
gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren so drüber
bröseln aber wirklich nur hier und ganz
wenig die Stadt erreichen echt 2
fertig ist sonst reistorte
gefällst du dir ja
lass mal Sarah ein Foto machen und dann
wird probiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommt girls wir probieren warum steht da
nicht sagen aber Sarah hat er schon die
Spitze
so eine coole Torte
ich will nicht mit dir tauschen
mit der Torte nicht an das ist eine
schnelle Torte ist oder
wir haben die ich habe Freund
durchgerechnet nur so 30 Minuten
Zubereitungszeit
9 Minuten Backzeit und dann Kühlzeiten
stimmt zwar schnell zubereiten
also für mich ist aufwändig
also für mich
zusammen mische
Anke lasst euch den Vorrang
zerstört
Liebe
der Crunch Boden
[Gelächter]
Fishdom Tonkabohne ist die beste
aller aller Zeiten
der
lecker richtig lecker
der perfekt
nicht verraten wo ich heute abend bin
okay also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken
[Applaus]
[Musik]